it is an absolute Hive of activity
preparing Mass graves because they
simply can't cope with the number of
dead that they've suffered not only in
country that goes into the thousands
but also those that are being brought
over from turkey and other Mass grave
there
so many syrians fled over the border to
Turkey to safety what they thought was
safety from the war here because
remember this is a country that is still
very much at War
there are sanctions against it the
people here are complaining that they're
not getting any Aid through and if there
is any it is very very small so small is
to make hardly any difference whatsoever
they've had to cope with this Mass
natural disaster themselves completely
themselves